just when it looked like the felonious
payoffs to Donald Trump's mistresses
stuff was starting to wind down with the
sentencing to three years in prison for
Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen there's a
totally new story related to these
payoffs the Donald Trump's mistresses
and it just keeps getting worse and
worse for Trump the National Enquirer is
a gossip magazine it's owned by a
company called American media
incorporated also known as AMI
yesterday we learned within minutes of
the sentencing of Michael Cohen - three
years in prison we learned that ami is
now admitting that they made a hundred
and fifty thousand dollar payment to an
ex playboy model and Trump mistress
named Karen McDougal in coordination
with Donald Trump's 2016 presidential
campaign the goal of which was to
influence the results of the election in
other words to help Donald Trump defeat
Hillary Clinton federal prosecutors have
agreed not to prosecute Ami
in exchange for ami accepting
responsibility cooperating with an
investigation and committing to making
quote compliance improvements so that
this doesn't ever happen again right ami
had been the target of another federal
investigation and of course like
everyone associated with these payoffs
ami lied ami first said oh no no no
these expenditures have nothing to do
with the election we have First
Amendment rights these are not illegal
campaign contributions nothing to see
here
then federal prosecutors went to ami and
showed them what they have and instead
now am I saying yeah we did it and the
prosecutor's office is saying that ami
has provided quote substantial and
important assistance in an investigation
that is still going on isn't it funny
Pat or at least interesting that nobody
has any involvement or knowledge about
what these prosecutors are talking about
until they get in a room with the
prosecutors and then all of a sudden
everybody's very interested in
cooperating with the investigations yeah
it seems like they're saying something
that jogs their memory or maybe it's
that their lies are just not standing up
and then they're when they're presented
with some sort of jail time or
repercussions they flip and this is
particularly interesting because the
National Enquirer previously said they
have a quote safe full of trunk related
stories that they've worked on
successfully better that they s we would
say that they've successfully buried
that is a treasure trove that at any
point could explode and Donald Trump
could have 10 new scandals on his hands
and as shocking as it might be there
could be way more felony payoffs which
we might learn about remember Michael
Wolf's book fire and theory in that book
he quotes Steve Bannon Trump's advisor
former advisor as saying that one of
Donald Trump's attorneys quote took care
of 100 women during the presidential
campaign not all of those of course
would be former mistresses they may have
been individuals who had stories to tell
that that were not stories of being
former mistresses but that is the
allegation in Michael Wolf's book and
there are rumblings and I want to be
really clear these are merely rumblings
there are rumblings about Donald Trump
forcing a woman to have an abortion and
paying for it which would Bing bring a
whole new meaning to the term the
abortion bill as something other than a
legislative proposal and you would
imagine of course that if Trump indeed
did force a mistress to have an abortion
that his evangelical supporters would
immediately abandon him but I think that
they'd still find a way to defend his
actions because of you know Hillary's
emails and she would have started a war
with Syria or something like that send
me your thoughts about how far do you
think this goes and by this I mean the
sort of umbrella of hush money payments
mistresses shutting women up that type
of thing how far do you think it goes
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show one
of today's sponsors is Skillshare which
is an incredible online learning
community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video we'll get to
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than ten bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up